and that system for her him is always
evolving 100
what is true today might not be true
tomorrow in my mind i am a living and
breathing counter puncher to the reality
of the day
that's a great way to say it i'm going
to keep this one you got it
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation how are you very excited
today for a new podcast uh it is late
late late summer in new york city and
for us east coaster that means it's u.s
open time and we have a tremendous guest
today talking about a subject matter
that i have a lot of passion for i grew
up loving hacking with tennis and
watching it i still think michael
chang's paris
run is something i think about every
time this summer starts because i'll
never forget it and uh and have been a
long time fan of tennis and uh
as my career has evolved uh
i've really become friendly with a lot
of the guys and gals on the tour and
enjoy it
and my guest today is one of the most
significant
um individuals in the sport today some
people call him the commissioner of
tennis uh and i'm excited to yap with
him and really as we go on this journey
of
leaning into your passions and doing
what you love and really mindset you
want to talk about a sport
that really leans into mindset and even
the ebbs and flows in a single match are
fascinating the highs of highs the lows
of those as many of you know novak
joker is uh is my favorite tennis player
i legitimately every time he's down two
sets to love in a match i go to social
media and say and now it's gonna start
and he legitimately
lands it for me eight out of ten times
and so uh patrick it's real really a
great pleasure to have you on the show
why don't you tell everybody who you are
and a little bit about yourself and then
i'll get into some questions
thank you gary um
[Music]
i didn't know you were such a tennis fan
happy to know
um well i'm i'm i'm a tennis fan i i
really i am a tennis fan i i fell in
love with tennis when i was four years
old as a kid
uh i used to be a player when i was
young and then i had to stop tennis
because my parents thought it was not
a real thing yeah
a too risky thing too risky they didn't
want me to take that risk
and then my my life 10 years later
my life became tennis i be i started my
own tennis academy when i was 26
in france
my academy became the
the biggest tennis academy in europe and
i started coaching
and i coached a lot of i mean a lot a
few top players and the last one that
i'm still working with for now uh almost
10 years is serena williams so i'm a
tennis coach
and then i started to do some businesses
in tennis my tennis academy is one and
then i started to do a few others so i
would define myself as first a coach a
tennis coach a coach in general because
i think
coaching is uh
is helping people achieve their their
potential and i think
[Music]
whether it's tennis or anything else
it's
we're kind of doing the same the same
job
and uh and i'm also a
businessman
let's go to the beginning why at four
you saw it on the telly
no my parents
it was the 70s in the seventies tennis
was big huge huge
we had the borg mcenroe
chris abbott connors chris everett
navratilova it was
tennis was huge so
my parents like many other people
started to play tennis they were not
young
but uh they started to play and they
were going to the club every weekend the
club became our
weekend yeah second home we can second
home totally and i was with other kids
and we were hacking we started to play
yeah right and i thought
and were you good at it right away yeah
i was good yeah actually i was as a kid
i was i was suffering a lot from a lot
of problems including
[Music]
very severe shyness a lot of anxiety
crisis at night
and the tennis court was the only place
where i felt good i felt confident i
felt
i was worth something also because i was
bad at school i was struggling
everywhere and the tennis tennis saved
my life
also because that was the only place
where i was somebody and i was worth
something
in the way that i want to start to
evolve my podcast a little bit i want to
jump in here
you know listening to patrick right now
literally what was going through my
brain was
[ __ ] that's what business was for me
i
wasn't shy but i was incredibly
emotionally charged
i i
i was so empathetic
and so competitive
that i basically cried twice a day every
day
my mom used to tell me if you don't stop
crying i'm going to give you something
to cry about
that's how much i was crying between 5
and 13
either because i lost in something
because i was so crazy or because
somebody picked on somebody in school
and that would make me cry because i was
so emotionally charged and business
selling lemonade washing cars selling
baseball cards
was my place of worth because i also my
report cards right here i was an
atrocious student
and so
it's really funny i very much understand
because that also then became my life
and that became my outland i guess why
i'm interrupting and jumping in is if
you're listening right now one important
thing to tell a lot of parents
is
being okay with kids finding other
outlets that aren't your ideology their
outlet may be chess it might be youtube
i think about all the parents that
stopped their kids from playing video
games when today that kid would be
making millions playing video games
parents are good at looking at the past
very bad at looking at the future when
you find passion you have to groom that
passion as a coach which is what a
parent does and so it's an interesting
tie-in okay so
you get really good as a kid like do you
think at 7 8 12 13 i'm gonna be
professional does it get that serious
for you
yeah it's not even a question for me
it's
it's for sure so at nine years old i am
gonna be a professional tennis player
100 okay keep going maybe i don't say it
but in my mind there is nothing else in
tennis like
literally saturday and sunday i spent
eight hours each day on the court and i
know i mean after one or two hours the
guy on the other side is tired and then
another guy comes but i i don't leave
the court i stay on the court and i play
with maybe four different guys
so
i don't know if i literally said it to
myself i will be a professional
but my life is only about tennis because
my mind is only about ten right monday
through fridays about tennis saturday
and sunday you're physically playing
monday through friday you're in your
head totally same with me that's why i
was bad at school i couldn't think about
school i was thinking about what i was
gonna sell this weekend i mean it i
understand it um
house
so you i listened carefully so at 16
there was a crossroads where your
parents were like no more but at 15 16
you know humbly self-aware
could have you gone on the tour in a
serious way yeah i think so too i really
think so and that's why it was tough
first of all because it was my life
um and you know i just want to say a few
words about what you said because you
said it was extremely true i would add
something i think parents also
um
envision something for their children
which is their vision their what they
would love to do what they think is
great
and i think that's the major mistakes
that they do they should think what is
what is my son or my daughter feel is
great for him or her what does he love
what is he good at it's not a question
about what you want
because being parents is not what you
want
it's helping your children achieve what
they're good at and what they're
passionate about
it's probably what you see done poorly
by other coaches in your sport
i'm sure without even knowing but you
can already tell i know because i know
how life works there are coaches that
are fairly accomplished
but they have a system and that player
must come into their system which is why
they can't be consistently great as a
coach a consistently great coach is in
the business of reverse engineering
listening and evolving and filling out
the opportunities predicated on the
person
100 right thank you i'm saying that
every single day of my life
and it changes right i'm sure serena
using her as the icon she is i have a
very funny feeling that 10 years ago
what she needed for her game from your
perspective based on what she was was
different than it was six years later
100 and what i explained every day is
that this is the thing that i created in
my tennis academy
i
i didn't want to create a system that
the players should fit in
my goal is to create a system that is
different for each player so i start
every collaboration with every player
with a white page and i learn the player
and once i know the player because i
learned
the player then i create
a system that is the best system for him
and that system for her him is always
evolving 100
what is true today might not be true
tomorrow in my mind i am a living and
breathing counter puncher to the reality
of the day
that's a great way to say it i'm gonna
keep this one you got it all right so
now your heart are you heartbroken are
you mad at your parents or given that
era which that was common it was pain
you evolve and so what did you do those
next 10 years i assume you went to
university and then what job did you
take
so first i was extremely mad at my
parents you have no idea like literally
they destroyed my life that's how i felt
yeah and it's not that they said you
stopped but they didn't support me so i
know
right so in a way
unfortunately your entrepreneurship part
didn't kick in yet you couldn't pay for
it totally yes
and so
and the the interesting thing is i
really hated my parents for many years
because of what happened
and 10 years after and that's when i
started martinez academy i realized
that everything that happened was my
responsibility and my fault i love you
for that really 100 i love you for that
and that changed my life when i realized
that i actually believe that
accountability
is the secret potion for happiness
i really believe that
i think people hate accountability they
love to point fingers instead of thumbs
they like to blame bathroom breaks
instead of themselves
keep going
so
keep going so so when you decided to
lean into accountability because i'm
sure
just even getting us knowing about you
from afar and now getting a quick sense
of you
you're in your head from 16 to 26 about
tennis
yeah and so you finally got to that
place of
adding the ingredient of accountability
to the passion which turned the whole
[ __ ] thing 100 i what i did
you know i started working and actually
i worked in my father's company because
i didn't know anything about business
and he said come learn a job at least i
said and what kind of company was it it
was a renewable energy he he was
one of the first ones to do that
yeah
actually his company became really big
he was at the stock market also in the
us it was the other company in the us
one in france he's a great businessman
and he said i mean do you have siblings
i'm sorry i have one one brother who's
younger and he's a guitar professional
guitarist so kind of same story as me we
had something on the side
that we were really good at
so my father said listen you don't know
what to do because i said i have no idea
what to do my life is
i said okay i'm going to learn a job so
i i started to work with not with him
actually but in the company for 10 years
and literally at every lunch break
i was going to the tennis
i was eating in front of the courts and
i was watching either people were
playing like random people or
looking at the course and imagining
everything that could be achieved on
that chord
i was really doing like like queen's
gambit right yeah did you see that yeah
you were you were visualizing exactly
exactly
and then yes uh so i learned his job the
job and then ten years after my father
told me you're ready we can start to be
business partners and i knew my life was
easy then if i would say yes
and i told him that i i mean i thanked
him a lot and i said no i mean thank you
but i'm lucky i have a passion like most
people don't have passion i have one
and i feel like my pas i didn't fulfill
my passion so i want to come back to
tennis but i want to
the thing i suffered the most from if i
think about it and i thought about it at
that time was that my parents didn't
believe in me tennis wise they didn't
think i would be great so they said do
something else
and i realized how powerful it is to
believe in people and how powerful it is
for people to have people who believe in
them
so i said to my father i'm gonna go back
to tennis because i wanna i wanna finish
my story it's not gonna be the same
story but i think i have a story with
this sport and what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna help
young players
achieve their dreams this is the thing
that i was not given the chance to do so
i will give people the chance to do what
i couldn't and what's interesting as i'm
thinking this through is
then you go into that career and you're
met with parents
that are actually the reverse of your
parents
parents that are delusional
a lot of times on how big the ups right
if they're coming to that academy
these are parents now that actually all
believe that their child which is
amazing but
an interest right you know every parent
i assume going to a real academy if it
became the biggest in europe is
literally in belief that their child is
going to be number one in the world
they do believe that the child is going
to be number one and i think it's great
honestly it's great of course you know
when is it all when does it when did you
know because everything
is i was born in the soviet union
there's a great russian saying that i
just said which stands for everything's
at its best when it's balanced
you know i think a lot about ambition
mixed
with practicality
when does a parent thinking a kid's
number one going to an a cat you know
again i'm projecting here so jump in
they go into the best academy in europe
they all think at some point they're way
up there and now i'm just gonna take a
cliche kid a kid comes in they think
they're gonna be number one in the world
and very quickly they meet six other
kids that they're not even at this
remotely at the same level
they're going through that calibration
of oh [ __ ] here's four 15 year olds that
are way better than me nine-year-olds
whatever it is
but their parents are still pushing at
the gym when when is that belief that
their kids number one
become not a good thing
that's an extremely good question uh
there is uh
i really love people who support their
kids and unfortunately
i think it's it's the greatest thing
that they can do to be the best
supporters of the kids but a lot of
those parents live vicariously through
their kid right that's true that's true
but still
it's better than not believing in your
kids and respect much better respect i'm
ten times better
uh
that's the best present you can give to
people to believe in them what happens
when the kids what happens when the kid
loses passion and the parent does it
that's where it gets murky right no
you're right but i'm going to steal this
i still want to answer the first
question
uh
you can be reasonable when you want to
be a champion it's not about reason
richard williams from day one said they
will both be number one in the world
the father of coco golf
from day one i know them i know coco
since she's 10.
when she was 10 he was believing she's
going to be the greatest of all times
and he believes a million percent and
this has so much power
and brings so much belief in
their son or their daughter
the value of that you have no idea you
know i understand you know
you know what's funny i'm sorry
interrupt i i fully know
i'm the byproduct of a mother that told
me i was gonna be the greatest in the
world and i believe it
and that's why it works and and when you
shoot you know one of the thing i know
where you're going because i get so
upset with parenting that tries to limit
their child because you have to go for
the moon because if they end up on the
top of a tree that's better than on the
ground if they end up on the top of a
mountain that's better on the ground but
if you don't extend it to the moon the
[ __ ] are we doing
and you will never achieve something
bigger than what you see if you see your
child being at that level
it will never be better than that level
100 so
i mean
unless that child is lucky enough to
have an emotional stronghold within
themselves and start to value other
people's opinions besides their parent
which is why rocket which is why music
has always been powerful right it's why
fame is interesting fame used properly
can be one of the great superpowers in
the world because it gives
somebody that a child admires
the leverage of that child to dream
bigger than the parents are dreaming for
them totally but we always come back to
people believing in other people man
it's always the same thing so tell so
now you start the academy is it an
instant hit because you have this 10
years of learning you probably have some
of your dad's natural business dna you
have the passion or was it a struggle
upfront how did it go from the beginning
the start was tough yeah i was just
renting two courts in a club right at a
time when it was not expensive and
and right so bad time slots to keep the
cost down yes it's the greatest time
arbitrage i love it keep going when you
look back it's the best moment because
you have to figure out how to make it
starting from scratch
and after two years i realized that i
had no chance because i was nobody in
tennis no credibility
never coached anyone
so i didn't have a lot of things for
myself except an incredible motivation i
have no idea an incredible ambition
because i went at that time to all the
agents which i didn't who i didn't know
and i said listen i'm gonna be the best
i'm gonna build the biggest academy in
europe you have to help me now and they
all told me do it and we'll help you
i'll say no but i'll do it
did you not find one
my i think the greatest part of my
career is being that one person because
i think if you're right one out of ten
times for everybody who's in a luxurious
position in their business life or
emotionally as a human
being right once out of 10 times to the
patricks that come to you will offset
the other nine losses
you didn't fight you didn't find one
person no and actually it's very
european
probably i have a very
anti-entrepreneurship
you know point of view like i i i'm from
europe i'm born in eastern europe but
it's it baffles me the lack of like the
the culture and europe is so fragmented
this is such a broad statement and
there's tons of amazing entrepreneurs
but like
[ __ ] man i wish there was more
entrepreneurship across europe it would
help europe a lot i agree keep going
right
yeah um
so i
thought i need a name i need a name
because i need credibility if i want to
convince
no i needed for my academy like a coach
because if i have a coach's name that is
really famous of course the kids will
want so what happened i
happened to meet uh
the greatest coach in tennis at that
time his name was bob rhett he was
australian as he was unfortunately died
last year
and um i found a way to have one hour
meeting with him and i convinced him and
i want to say just one word about that
when at 16 my parents decided not to
follow me in my dreams and i said i took
accountability for that
i understood that i should have
convinced them and this is what i failed
nobody else did that's right and i did
fail
because i i was not i haven't been able
at that time to listen to them and if i
had understood what they were scared of
i for example
i would just convince them correct from
that time i decided from now
i'm going to convince people right
because the same way you coach people
and watch them it's just reverse
engineering if you listen yeah totally
100 so you use that skill set you
understood at this point obviously look
you were 16. it's hard you know to be
fully baked at 16. now at 28 or 29
you're you've got it and you're able to
convince the best coach in the world to
use your academy
to train there to kind of his name give
me his name and he mentored me but it
was not in the deal but we had a great
relationship so he helped me
and it became babrita academy for the
first six years so we did six years
together
and one day he left
he said i'm gonna do my own tennis
academy fair enough but then i thought
wow that was the worst investment in my
life i invested six years on a brand on
a name
and this brand because now it's
now he's my competitor that's right so
it's terrible that's why i put my name
so i decided okay when i never make that
mistake again
i mean i get it that's important in life
yeah if you if you keep doing the same
mistakes call me once
100 so
and what happens because in those six
years
i'm sure at the moment it was the worst
feeling but in hindsight now that's
what's good about a couple more gray
hairs right you realize so much good
happened in those six years that gave
you the leverage for what you're about
to say happen next yes you're right and
i wanted to give up honestly i was so
disappointed like you felt like you felt
let down yes on a personal yeah makes
sense by the way this is an important
point everybody that's listening
if you you know
the gentleman that left and uh god rest
his soul
you know
when you're that person with the name
sometimes you go through the same
feelings
you know you're renting your name and
you had the leverage and you know
in partnerships especially the one you
described very tricky
people are coming from very opposite
tension points
and you know there was probably a point
where he
had resentment from his perspective or
he saw a missed opportunity
and so i have a lot of compassion for
both of you in that scenario
um
but
a lot of people do give up and become
cynical and angry at this crossroads and
do actually spend most of their energy
tearing down looking backwards
again kudos to you
i'm sure because of that chip on your
shoulder from 16 gave you the energy to
give it another swing and a new version
you're right and i was very disappointed
on a personal level but if i look back
it's the best thing that ever happened
yes
the two things the fact that he trusted
me was unbelievable i was nobody i was a
kid i was 28 i didn't know anything
this guy he gave trusted me he gave me
my chance and and like he took me under
his wings and by the way
him leaving is the best thing to happen
to you because that's why you're sitting
here right now
100 000
so what happened what's your next big
break so now you got to build up your
own brand yeah what happens because i
assume some kids came through in those
six years something must have happened
right yeah i i decided to
speak to all my teams so i had everyone
around i said guys so i'm going to put
my name because i don't want the same
thing to happen again
but i'm not a tennis coach so now i have
to become a tennis coach i was like 33
years old i never get the guys told me
but you never give a tennis lesson in
your life what are you talking about
like they were all professional coaches
and i said to them well guys you're
right
but i learned fast so i'm going to start
now
and i gave myself 10 years to win a
grand slam as a coach which is i mean
99.9 percent of the coaches will never
win a grand slam as a as coaches in
their life and it took me 10 years to
win and we i won 10 with serena so
yeah so this my plan worked and it
worked and i always say that for two
reasons first of all
you couldn't find someone more motivated
than me i think it was impossible i was
literally thinking coaching day and
night waking up at night with ideas
writing them down
and the thing that was an asset at that
time is that i didn't know anything a
hundred blind eyes are dangerous
that's what i was saying yeah blind eyes
are dangerous
my entire career
every industry i've gone into i knew
nothing about
and i'm always dominant because all i do
is try to figure out what's value
not how people did it
i had exactly the same strategy i
thought well i don't have the tactical
tools the technical tools
i didn't learn anything
but i have to figure out how to make
this player win
which which led to why it worked because
the technical tools are a commodity
the mental tools are not
the seeing the gray is not
the commodity
anybody can teach you a proper forehand
or a backhand over time can be taught
you can watch [ __ ] videos the grey of
being number one in the world
is the actual punchline
yeah and i was all about
how to win
how does my player win points how does
she lose his points
uh and how can i help her
who's your first significant player in
that 10-year run who let's say had
got to the quarters or who was your
first significant player marcos
baghdadis oh yes so he reached the final
of the open remember i started with him
he was 13 and a half years old
um he was at my tennis academy and when
then he got when he got older and
started to play on tour he asked me to
coach him so that was a big moment oh
yeah huge huge and what was that what
was the if i asked you privately and now
it's going to be publicly what's the
thing you're most proud of that you
helped marcos with whether it was by the
way whether it's following the narrative
we've been talking about and something
about mind or maybe if it's just
actually something technical if i asked
you
the thing that you're most proud of or
you feel good about it feels nice inside
of you something subtle or specific that
you helped him with thoughts you know
you have to understand how people work i
mean work how they process how they
process yes what makes them
have the will the motivation
you know and put everything on the table
yeah and marcos was all about emotions
all about it about all about love
if he would feel love
from you and for you
he would die on the court
and i think i made him feel that that's
awesome
it's really cool
what happens next what's the next
significant player uh
i worked with i mean
they were not super famous that's okay
but they were good players and they
become
better with me every time and that's
what i'm always doing and that's where
you were getting confidence right as
this was happening you're like to your
point right yes
if you were one if they were 113 in the
world they come to you and they're 89
that means something 100 and i always
say we are all the result of all our
experiences that's right when you create
positive experiences
you build the feeling that you are good
at what you're doing you become and you
become better affirmation affirmation
affirmation yes and especially when you
keep that mindset that i had from day
one which is my strength which is i'm
good because i always start thinking i
know nothing and i kept that humility is
foundational
because
some coaches have a result very good
results with one player and they think
oh now i know correct and this is when
they're done it's finished and then they
repeat the same recipe all their life
that's not coaching that's right
coaching is a different recipe every
time you have to discover how to make a
great
bolognese pasta like if it's the first
time you're gonna do it if i asked you
a coaching regret
or in hindsight
you could have done something a little
bit better with a player because you
didn't see it but that player taught you
and you didn't make the same mistake in
the future does anything stand out like
i'm not about regress i never had
regrets yes i don't regret anything in
my life and i did mistakes like
everybody yeah
the only thing i can regret because but
just because of one reason because it
destroyed my relationship with him is
what happened with marcos
at the end
uh because i was not on i was not
listening to him anymore and
understanding him anymore and i was he
was doing so well i wanted him to keep
going
and uh
i was not able to listen anymore and i
was more like acting like a bad father
like i own him he's like my son so he
can't he can't go a different direction
from the one i want and this is a th
was not coaching anymore and i was not
in a coaching
relationship with him anymore it became
deeper emotional exactly and i read
which is why you're empathetic to your
father about what he did with you
totally and i reacted too much
emotionally rather than as a coach and
he didn't understand me at that time and
and our relationship became bad and uh
and this this was this was really bad
and if i look at that i was a terrible
coach
at the end of the relationship with
marcos and
this
was the biggest lesson for me i never
did that again never ever i always found
a way to take emotion away and when i
felt every time i felt emotional
in my job as a coach i was always
shutting up
taking time away yep and coming back
only when i was ready because the
emotion was thank you for sharing that
that's that's going to help a lot of
people thank you so
i have an interesting question
just for fun this is just my tennis
nerdum this by the way i'm sorry to
everybody i'm just going completely i've
been doing pretty well in a linear line
but i'm just going completely random now
because i'm too excited to ask this i've
been waiting the whole time to ask this
question actually
observing from afar
and being very in the sport
which player
as you've been very deep over the last
10 15 20 years whatever it's been do you
believe
was most side railed by injuries and had
she or he not been hurt
they would have been
a number one player or an iconic player
just complete tennis fun chat i'll give
you a second because it's a fun question
okay so someone who has been so injured
he would have been number one over the
last 50 yeah over the last 10 15 years
20 years you've been so deep in this
whether it was early on like you have
such a great eye that you're a
professional you know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about not me like a fan
ju
if i said to you that question somebody
who's come along in the last 20 years
that you're disappointed because you
would have loved to see them play
her him at their highest level but
unfortunately it was injuries that kind
of derailed them less so mindset because
i think a lot of those people come along
too but injuries i'm just genuinely
curious no i there is one i think of
unfortunately i don't remember his name
and he's american and he was
unbelievable he's the same generation as
marty fish
of course i don't remember his name
because he didn't do so well but so he
came up with fish blake those guys right
yes and he was well somebody who's
listening right now give your guests on
twitter yeah
describe them a little bit because that
will probably help some of the hardcore
fans remember incredibly talented
playing very flat
very loose
great i mean he had everything this guy
and he had like injuries all his career
and he never made it to very high i
think it was top 100 it was top 100 i
think maybe once but not for long
and it would have been top 10 for sure
in your subjective opinion eisner eyes
or you know like all these guys he was
on a different planet
i mean we're talking about guys who were
top ten yeah so he was
for me at least able to be top 10 uh if
not more wow and uh i i know a lot of
people think the same by the way you
just can't recall his name right now yes
and and there is another one i'm
thinking of but she's still playing it's
uh andresku i think andre school has a
huge game
mentally she's so strong
so strong
but so young and
still
i mean already struggling with a lot of
injuries and i think that
for her the question about
having a great career or not
is only about managing her body to stay
away from injuries it is going to be the
fight of her all her career
who was your favorite player growing up
so strangely because i was playing
servant volley and richard volley i was
always at the net my favorite player was
bjorn borg
of course and then patrafter late later
for me
the player i've loved the most watching
i loved stefan edberg like loved really
yes i i don't even know why what did you
love about him
he seemed small
he seemed kind of like
he you know what i loved about him it
was just timing
i l i grew up you know i loved mcenroe
as a kid east coast i'm a hot head i did
all the stupid things on the court like
back in row at five at 7 8 9 10 11 12
when i played a lot
but then lendl came along and kind of
took that from mcenroe and i hated lendl
right i was i was you know my parents
left the soviet bloc so [ __ ] you and he
was very mean looking and i was scared
of lendl and and
edberg kind of like you know i liked
matt spinlander a little bit you know
but like edberg kind of had that little
period in that edberg owned that little
window for two or three years in between
the lendel era and then when the whole
you know sampras and agassi thing
started
i liked i liked his net game
you know because i also played that well
i was small and i wasn't strong so i was
incredibly intuitive so i played at the
net a ton
it's also why i already brought up
michael chang right smaller you know it
it fit me and it was the height of when
i was watching
yeah i i liked also stephen berg and the
great guy also
uh i think it was too clean for me i
love the the rafter style like was so
physical at the jumping very animal
that's what i loved with him he was an
animal at the net you know it's funny
the reason i love novak the most and
right from the beginning
there's there's
a moment that novak does often and i'm
always wondering if people understand
what he's doing because it is how i live
my life
my chip
is less around my parents and it's more
against the world
i love being an underdog
i might even right now as i'm telling
you this story my chemic my competitive
chemicals are moving i can feel it
i believe that novak had it better than
anybody ever
because the world
loves rafa and federer
and so
my favorite moment in tennis ever is a
recent phenomenon which is
when novak plays
wimbledon and is andy and i love you so
much
and the whole [ __ ] world is against
him
that their classic match four years ago
or one or three years ago
i was at a bar eating with the kids and
the whole place
is rooting
raj
and there was a big point in that fifth
set
like a stunning point that novak won and
i got so stumped loud yeah and and and
everybody looked at me and a guy came
over to me and said you're not really
rooting for him i go with all my [ __ ]
heart
but what novak does and i [ __ ] love
this so [ __ ] much there's no business
version of it so i can never really do
it only when i buy the jets and win a
lombardi trophy will i be able to feel
this
where
he
wins the match or a point
and he just looks at the entire crowd
and just says [ __ ] you now what i love
it that look he does it's everything to
me
and
so it's funny that you say too clean
because it's funny
i by far my favorite players have been
more dirty
but the height of me watching all the
tournaments you know on espn watching
cincinnati like the height of my like
consumption because then i started
working at 14 and had no time to watch
tv um
was ed berg but but what novak
represents right now speaks to me the
most because nobody's rooting for him
nobody and there is another reason why
he is whis you are totally right in what
you're saying for sure he uses the
he uses the fact that he's an underdog
and he's using the fact that people are
against me for in his favor to to become
better to uh to to find more
more
great
but the second thing that he has is the
belief
because if you go back in time maybe 15
years ago
rafa and roger were winning absolutely
everything correct and i know all i knew
all the top tens at that time already
and i was speaking to them and all of
them were telling me it's impossible to
win a grand slam because those two guys
there's they're in a different level
different planet
and i remember a young guy 19 coming up
and playing finally roger in a grand
slam first round so he was not nobody
yet
and he's interviewed the day before and
in the press he says i'm gonna beat him
and i remember the press saying who the
[ __ ] is this guy who does he think he is
still cocky
and i remember him saying i'm not cookie
i believe in myself
and this guy
who was as you understood novak
ended up beating the two greatest of all
times
became number one
and will pro pro probably end up being
the greatest of all times because he
believed in himself
more than anyone even at a time when it
was almost impossible to believe in
oneself beating the two guys so that's
the power of belief and of course it
comes also from your education
from the fact that i'm coming back to
that people believe in you so much
uh but it's also something that you
build throughout your experiences and
you reach a point where the belief is so
strong that nothing can nothing can
destroy it and it's it's the biggest
gas you can put in your car what happens
to a player that's number one for a
while
when she or he
what what is typical in your opinion
of when they lose the belief
so what's amazing about my life because
i'm i think through sports 24 7 but in
business it's not a winner take all game
you know it's not like i'm playing like
i'm winning and many people that i look
at that i know are like me they're
winning and i'm happy for them because
the world of business everyone can win
really even if you're competing against
somebody in business there's so much
market in tennis there's a tournament so
only one person wins
i will never lose the belief we're
talking about ever ever ever i'm blindly
religious that i'm going to be the
greatest businessman of all time
and then there's really no affirmation
one way or the other along the way that
i go
but i wonder
with a john mcenroe because he has to be
believing or connors or a becker or an
agassi or a sampras or like
what have you seen
or what tends to happen
or can you notice when you can see the
switch of for three and a half years
they believe that
and something's happening whether it's
an outside force or an inside force
that clicks it the other way very very
interesting question first of all all
most of the very very very good young
players go climb the rankings very fast
so they're in a success
cocoon cocoon exactly and at some point
when you reach the typically really top
sometimes you hit the wall one time two
times three times you know you play okay
you play a grand slam semi you lost you
lose to novak and then you lose to rafa
and then you lose to roger
and
after a certain time you stop to believe
and i can see it from outside because i
see that suddenly
there are some things if you really pay
attention you can see it that's why for
example they would they would take a
coach that is not too expensive
certainly oh
interesting
because you don't invest anymore in your
career okay you send me a very good
message it's quite clear but then even
going to the talking about the best you
know talking about serena for example
who is probably the great i mean she is
the greatest of all times no no no no
not probably both sides
uh she's just 23 grand slams and i
started working with hershey at 13.
which is already incredible insane
insane
when i start working with him she's at a
period of time when she's
doubting because two years without
winning a grand slam
uh it's long for someone like her yes
it's long and she's number seven in the
world and
you know yeah she's she's doubting you
know anyone can doubt of course even the
greatest
and when i start with her i have a very
clear image of
of her because i look very closely even
from afar because i i was not coaching
her before
and i have a clear idea of how she
processes and how she thinks and when i
started working together we started
working together the first tournament we
she plays is wimbledon
and she reaches the semifinals
and when she's in the semis i will
remember that all my life i'm at the
restaurant in wimbledon and she runs to
me
with a big smile and she says guess what
whatever happens at the end of the
tournament i'm gonna be top three in the
world and i can't believe she's saying
something like that interesting
i can't believe it
so i asked though i answer
and what
she says he's great no
i said what are you talking about being
three in the world is great you're
[ __ ] thirteen
yeah are you joking
i can't believe it
so she doesn't answer and in the evening
she sends me a text message and she said
sorry for what i said today that was
ridiculous
number three is terrible and number two
also even worse even worse and
the the lesson i learned at that moment
is even the greatest of all times who
process i mean you have no idea how they
think because for her number two is the
worst thing on the planet
even them
when that comes
you can start to think 100 life is long
you go through journeys i love that and
what happened in that wimbledon she won
it and then she did singles and doubles
three weeks after she won olympic gold
medals in singles in doubles one month
after she won the us open and at the end
of the year she won the masters
and then two months after she was number
one and she stayed three and a half
years in a row
number one in the world
love it
love it what have we not touched on as
we wrap up here anything that
you want people to have we can talk uts
but it's gonna be too long i think so i
i want you to ask him
um since we don't edit that was maha in
the background
always fun to have you always fun to
have you uh on the podcast um
yeah where do you think tennis is going
well if i look at the the demographics
they don't look good
uh a lot of studies have been made on
tennis uh and on golf and other sports
by the tv channels and they found out
that the average age of the the fan of
tennis who is following tennis and
watching tennis on a regular basis is 61
years old which is very old 64 for golf
but it's very old and
and it's getting older every year and
i'm i mean i'm i'm upset with that's uh
and i'm i'm all worrying also you know
for our sport and
i start to
try to understand why and
if i look at the situation i what i
understand is that
the tennis format is a very old format
it's more than a year a century ago yes
it was created
and the the way people consume that type
of content has
completely changed in the last 10 15
years with the digital so what people
are watching it to today
it's
contents which are short dynamic
immersive and authentic mma
esports exactly so
tennis is long
sometimes very long yesterday five hours
yes
slow the time when the ball is in play
is less than 15 percent of the time
that's right
not immersive at all and not authentic
because they all pretend they're the
nicest people on the planet and you know
this which is
now you're really going into why i love
novak versus the field
exactly oh
rodol it's harwood you listening to that
little subtle moment keep going my
friend
so i thought oh we have to do something
because the atp the wt the grand slams
are not going to change tennis and i
don't think we should change tennis
tennis is beautiful the way it is yes we
have a billion fans yes yes they're
getting older because our fan base is
the fan base that we fell in love with
tennis in the 70s and the 80s
and we're not renewing our fan base and
we're not reaching out to the young
generation and if you think about it it
even gets scarier because if you think
about
raj rafa novak serena you're talking
about global icons they're not unknown
they're they're pretty [ __ ] famous in
the scheme of things to a 20 and 30 and
40 year old so you've got a golden era
of celebrity
and yet you still have this problem it's
not like you know as you know there's
been pockets sometimes when we have
stars transitioning where some people
sneak in a couple of cheap grand slams
that aren't all time this is not one of
them and so for that to be the case it
becomes double concerning
it is
and uh so we're not renewing at our fan
base and we're not reaching out to the
young generation so as tennis has to
stay the way it is
i decided to create a second league
which would be
in a way complementary to the mainly to
the to the league that we all know atp
wta grand slams a second league with the
goal to reach out to the new generations
so
in parallel in our pockets that don't
disrupt the core schedules exactly like
you know my favorite football league i'm
an american football fan to the nine
there was a league in the 80s called the
usfl and i loved it why because it
played in the spring
it didn't disrupt the nfl um
unfortunately the ownership there
decided they had to go against the nfl
they sued the nfl and it failed but it's
too bad because the league had momentum
they had real players reggie white steve
young iconic players jim kelly
and it could have been a great league
and then i would have gotten more
football um and i've always thought that
the biggest mistake of when somebody
tries to disrupt the establishment
is they don't play the pockets of
reverse engineering the white space and
it's funny to hear you say this i didn't
know this
you're basically doing a league version
of what you do for an athlete you're
playing around the reality instead of
trying to create the conflict exactly
yeah and i think there is a space for
everyone and i think it's great for
tennis and when did you start
i started last year
right after the confinement in france
all right and then i hope it and it's a
little challenging exactly and i said
i'm gonna do it and i want to do the
proof of concept yeah so i
imagined
i told the team listen guys imagine we
create tennis today knowing what we know
about how people consume that kind of
right content how would you do it so we
create something a match is 45 minutes
much less time between the the points
coaching at every point uh coaching at
every point every point they have cards
they have cards they can use cards to
have extra like i want one extra serve
at 45 minute oh interesting at 45
minutes it's over and whoever's winning
wins yes but it's four quarters of eight
minutes
every quarter is eight minutes
there is at every changeover there is an
interview it can be a celebrity oh so
you're really going i like it very
uts which means ultimate tennis showdown
i love it and so we did it
i had most of the top players who played
like zverev sitsi pass beretini
medvedev i mean most of them real
players we were broadcasted since day
one in more than a hundred countries in
the world
we streaming streaming very nice
also on our ttv platform we reach we
have more than a
1.3 million fans already on facebook
after just four events
we have more than 120 000 people who are
subscribers on our ott platform
so i mean for me the proof of concept is
made so now we're uh into a capital race
to go full good for you and to do a real
season only with 10 events because i
don't want to disrupt the http and the
wta 10 events 10 big events and this is
my thing
10 players only ten events ten cities
why ten players because i found out that
ninety percent does that mean somebody
has a buy
no i play with only ten players formula
one twenty twenty nine drivers
why because i found out that 90 of the
fans do not know 90 of the players
you're being very nice you know that
right
98 of the fans don't i mean really
because i'm really because i i've been
i've thought as an entrepreneur three
four years ago the reason i can answer
that is because i was like maybe i'm
going to disrupt tenant like it's so
real i think the opportunity is very
real i love that listen we've got to go
patrick thank you so so so much uh
everybody please uh please uh do you
have uh social handles where people can
follow you of course
spell it out my instagram yes
uh p maretoglu at the pinwheel you want
to spell that because there's a lot of
yeah what the [ __ ] is that
p-m-o-u-r-a-t-o-g-l-o-u
i love it thank you my friend thank you
very much for the invitation
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you